so
[Music]
good evening everyone thank you for
joining us on this
historic day it's an honor to be here
with all of you
when the president asked me to serve in
this role we talked about the importance
of bringing truth and transparency
back to the briefing room and he asked
me to ensure
we are communicating about the policies
across the biden harris administration
and the work his team is doing every
single day on behalf of all american
people
there will be times when we see things
differently in this room i mean among
all of us
that's okay that's part of our democracy
and rebuilding trust with the american
people
will be central to our focus in the
press office and in the white house
every single day so we had a very busy
and active day
today as you all know but i wanted to
take a moment to
go through the 15 executive actions or
highlights of them i should say uh and
some of the age the
the steps that the president asked
agencies to take today
you should have all received copies of
the executive orders as well as the
accompanying fact sheets
but i want to take this moment to
highlight them for the american public
who are watching at home to combat the
deadly virus the president launched his
100 day masking challenge
asking americans to do their part and
mask up
for 100 days he's doing his part as well
issuing a mask mandate
that will require anyone visiting a
federal building or federal land or
using certain modes of public
transportation
to wear a mask he sends an executive
order
reversing trump's decision to withdraw
from the world
health organization this will strengthen
our own efforts to get the pandemic
under control by improving global health
and tomorrow we're not wasting any time
dr fauci will participate remotely in
the meeting of the world health
organization as the u.s head of
delegation
president biden also officially
appointed a covet 19 response
coordinator
a position and team we had already
previously announced
but made it official today to create a
unified national response to the
pandemic
and he reestablished the national
security team responsible
for global health security and bio
defense
the copa 19 pandemic has triggered an
almost unprecedented
housing affordability crisis he took
immediate action to confront the crisis
and asked relevant agencies to extend
nationwide moratoriums on evictions and
foreclosures the pandemic has also
increased the hardship on millions of
americans
who owe federal student loans in
response the president asked the
department of education
to extend the pause on student loan
payments and interest
he rejoined the paris climate agreement
putting the united states
back in a position to exercise exercise
global leadership
and advancing the objectives of the
ambitious agreement
sorry hope you're comfortable there's a
few more uh
and a second broad executive order will
roll back harmful
regulatory reversals made by the
previous administration to protect
public health
and the environment this order protects
our nation's treasures by re
reviewing the boundaries for several
national monuments
places a temporary moratorium on all oil
and natural gas leasing in the arctic
national wildlife refuge and
re-establishes the inter-agency working
group on the social cost of greenhouse
gases
he also launched a whole of government
effort to advance
racial equity and root out systemic
racism
from federal programs and institutions
he directed the secretary of homeland
security
in consultation with the attorney
general to take all
appropriate actions to preserve and
fortify daca
which provides temporary relief from
deportation to dreamers
young people who are brought to this
country as children
the president also put an end to the
muslim ban of policy rooted in religious
animus and xenophobia
he signed a proclamation effective
immediately
halting further funding or construction
of the previous administration's
border wall and terminating the
so-called national emergency used to
wastefully divert
billions for wall construction also
today
president biden sent an
immigration bill to congress the u.s
citizenship act modernizes our
immigration system
it provides hard-working people who have
enriched our communities and lived here
for decades an opportunity to earn
citizenship
the president's priority reflected in
the bill are to
responsibly manage the border keep
families together
grow our economy address the root causes
of migration from central america and
ensure that america can remain a refuge
for those fleeing
prosecution with that i'd love to take
your questions zeke why don't you kick
us off
thanks again first off congratulations
and uh one question about your role you
touched on this a little bit of the
topic
when you were up there do you see
yourself at your primary roles for
promoting the interests of the president
or are you there to provide us the
unvarnished truth so that we can share
that with you
well let me first say zeke um that i
come to this podium having
served both in the white house and at
the state department uh as the
spokesperson there
and i traveled the world on trips to
promote democracy uh where i saw the
power of the united states and of course
the power of this podium uh and the
power of truth
and the importance of setting an example
of engagement
and transparency so i will just state
because you gave me the opportunity i
have
deep respect for the role of a free and
independent press in our democracy and
for the role
all of you play as i noted earlier there
will be moments when we disagree
and there will certainly be days where
we disagree uh
for extensive parts of the briefing even
perhaps but we have a common goal
which is sharing accurate information
with the american people if the
president were standing here with me
today
he would say he works for the american
people
uh i work for him so i also work for the
american people
but his objective and his commitment is
to bring
transparency and truth back to
government uh
to share the truth even when it's hard
to hear um
and uh that's something that i hope to
deliver on in this role as well
and then go to just one subject of once
we're short on time
when will president biden begin making
some foreign legal calls who's on that
initial list and
during the transition he didn't speak
with president putin
uh does he plan on doing that and is he
going to discuss
retaliation for the solar winds hack on
the federal government
sure let me try to get to those and i'll
just note since zeke mentioned it i know
some of you have
another event this evening because we're
not fully done with the day so
uh we will have longer briefings in the
future but we'll try to get to as many
questions as possible
so uh his first call foreign leader call
will be on friday with prime minister
trudeau
i expect they will certainly discuss the
important relationship with canada
uh as well as uh his decision on the
keystone pipeline
that we announced today uh he i don't
have any plans or any
plans to read out for you in terms of a
call with president putin
i will note for you that i would expect
his early calls will be with partners
and allies
he feels it's important to rebuild those
relationships and to address
the challenges and threats we're facing
in the world on solar winds
we've spoken with this about this
previously a bit
prior to his inauguration i should say
today
we are of course we reserve the right to
respond
at a time in a manner of our choosing to
any cyber attack
but our team is of course just getting
on the ground today they're just getting
onto their computers uh
so i don't have anything to read out for
you or to
preview for you at this point in time
peter go ahead
let me i have a question for you on
policy first a quick housekeeping
question a short time ago president
biden said that he received a very
generous letter from president trump of
course he said it was
private he said i will not talk about it
until i talk to him is president biden
planning
to call now former president trump and
is this white house working in any way
to try to put the two in touch
well i think peter that was a reflection
of uh president biden's view and i was
with him when he was reading
the letter in the oval office right
before he signed the executive actions
uh was that this is a letter that was
private as he said to you all
uh it was both generous and gracious
and it was just a reflection of him not
planning to release the letter
unilaterally but
i wouldn't take it as an indication of a
pending call with
the former president let me ask you on
policy if i can quickly you talk
obviously your role is sort of uh in
terms of delivering the best information
to the american people on behalf of this
white house
the battle for truth may be as tough a
fight right now as is
the battle against coronavirus how do
you and president biden plan to combat
disinformation that in many ways led to
that assault we witnessed two weeks ago
today
on the capitol well i think peter
there are a number of ways to combat
misinformation one of them
is accurate information and truth and
data and
um and sharing information even when it
is hard to hear
and even when um it um is not
meeting the expectations of of people at
home who are desperate for this crisis
to be over
um we'll have more to share with you um
in the next
few days hopefully before the weekend
but uh what we plan to do
is not just return these daily briefings
monday through friday not saturdays and
sundays i'm not a monster but uh
on but also to return briefings with our
health officials and public health
officials we want to do those
regularly in a dependable way uh bait
with data
uh shared with all of you and with the
public so that they can also track
progress we're making on getting the
pandemic under control it relates to the
cabinet if i can quickly uh we know
president vines beginning without a
single member of his cabinet
confirmed what is your understanding on
how quickly those confirmations will
happen and when should we expect
additional nominations and
ambassadorships to be announced
well peter the desire to get his cabinet
in place
and get his team confirmed is front and
center for the president
he it is an issue a topic he discussed
with members of congress from both
uh the republican and democratic party
today during the course of the day in
the course of events uh
i think as we were coming out here uh
avril haynes
should be on her way to confirmation i
don't know if it's officially voted been
happened yet but she's on her way uh we
have prioritized
getting our national security team in
place given the crisis we're facing
given the importance of keeping the
american people safe
at this time but we are eager for those
to move forward quickly
in the coming days ideally tomorrow by
friday
we'd like to move them quickly it's
something that he is raising in uh his
conversations as we all are with members
of congress and their team thank you
thank you karen jen has president biden
invited congressional leaders to sit
down and talk about the coven relief
measure that he introduced
uh well he has been discussing uh the
coveted relief measures the entire
package that has as you know
unemployment insurance it has relief and
assistance for the american people
it also has money to reopen schools
which i know as a mother impacts all of
us uh
but he has been discussing that with
democrats and republicans since long
before he was sworn in today
uh today was a day where he had
conversations about working together
in terms of getting his team in place on
his agenda moving forward
but i expect he will be picking up the
phone uh in the coming days and having
more of those conversations
in terms of when he will meet in person
uh i will say
soon and we hope to have more of an
update on that for you soon as well do
you expect him to play in his
negotiations there was a lot of comments
today about his familiarity with the
senate
how involved will he be in that process
uh
he will be quite involved um there is
the issue that he wakes up every day
focused on
is getting the pandemic under control
the issue he goes to bed every night
focused on
is getting the pandemic under control
this package
is a pivotal step to doing that and it
has assistance
for the american people to make that
bridge financially
it also has essential funding for
vaccine distribution
he will be very involved um he will not
be the only one we have a whole team
here of senior staff of course but
as you noted he is not a stranger to the
senate he served there for 36 years
many of these people he has many of the
members on both sides of the aisle he
served with
uh over that time and i expect he will
be quite involved in the process
uh go ahead jen um so
on on this copic relief package uh
senator romney was already saying to
reporters today that he doesn't see a
need for another virus relief package
and he's the kind of republican vote
you're likely going to be trying to get
um so how long are you willing to try to
work
to get republican support before you
decide to go through the budget
reconciliation process
well uh as as you know uh because you
all cover it and as i've stated a couple
times here today we are in the middle
of an urgent crisis in this country it's
not just impacting
democrats it's impacting republicans
it's impacting red states and blue
states
um and this plan is intended to address
the suffering of the american people so
we
hope and and frankly we expect
republicans in congress
and democrats too will support
assistance that will bring relief to the
people they represent
this is a conversation he of course gave
a prime time address as you all know
last week it seems like a long time ago
but it wasn't
uh to announce his specifics and he has
already had a number of conversations
with democrats and the republicans
those will continue his clear preference
is to move forward with a bipartisan
bill there's no question about it
but we're also not going to take any
tools off the table for how the senate
house and senate can get this urgent
package done so we are only
less than a day has he been president of
the united states but uh he's going to
continue to work with members of both
parties to get it done
francesca go ahead thank you jen i do
have a question about reopening schools
but i just want to
pick up where she left off on that and
note that republicans including
lindsey graham who's expected to be the
senate budget committee
uh ranking member have already said that
the price tag
on the president's proposal is too high
for them
so is there any wiggle room on that
number
and has he already begun negotiations
with mitch mcconnell
well uh first the package wasn't
designed
uh with the number 1.9 trillion
as a starting point it was designed with
the components that were necessary to
give people the relief they needed
so what's challenging is what are you
going to cut are you going to cut
funding for vaccinations are you going
to cut funding for unemployment
insurance are you going to cut funding
for
reopening schools but it was laid out as
his proposal based on recommendations
from
economists recommendations from health
experts and
as you've also seen there have been uh
also an outpouring of support from
everyone from bernie sanders to the
chamber of commerce for the package and
the components in it
but this is a discussion it's a
conversation
and uh he is no stranger to the process
of bill making
so we're at the beginning of the process
and and as we continue there'll be
conversations with members of both
parties of
what will be in a final package and
rarely does it look exactly like
the initial package that is proposed
with regards to reopening schools
what level of vaccination in teachers or
students or level of testing
does the administration think would be
appropriate in order to meet the target
date that the president has set
um this is a great question and as i
noted at the banning and as a mom myself
i
want to know all the details as well
we're going to have more to share
from our health experts in the coming
days
and i will venture to get them in here
to give you all a briefing on the
specifics but we really want to
lean into them on their expertise on
that front go ahead
i'll come right to you right next go
ahead uh so uh president biden
a promise to end all new oil and gas
leasing on federal lands when he was a
candidate the
order that you just mentioned that he
signed today was much narrower than that
it's a temporary moratorium and it only
applies to anwar
and there's some debate about whether he
has the legal flexibility to even follow
through with his full promise
does the administration still have that
commitment today to
we do and and the um uh
the leases will be uh reviewed by our
team uh
we just have only been in office for
less than a day now
uh and i will just since you gave me the
opportunity just also confirmed for all
of you
all of our executive actions that we
released today were reviewed by the
career staff at the olc
um we went through that process in
advance of releasing them
um that took a great deal of work from
our policy teams but um
that was a vital part of the process for
us as well a little bit just about
the kind of the preparations for getting
the the white house ready
uh and safe for the the president the
new president
it's been reported that you did the 500
000 worth of deep cleaning could you
talk about the measures that you took
to ensure that the president is safe
well the i would refer you to the
general services administration who
oversees any steps like that
um what i can speak to if it's of
interest of the steps we're all taking
to make sure that we are safe he is safe
you are all safe
those include daily testing when we're
in the white house it includes
wearing n95 masks i wore it out of
course here today
and we'll continue to do that um it
includes stringent rules about social
distancing
um and abiding by that in the building
uh that keeps us safe but
we're also the president has asked us to
also be models to the american people
and that's vitally important to us as
well so there are a number of new
coveted
uh steps precautions that we've put in
place as of today
uh go ahead all the way in the back
thank you so much jen
thanks for doing this in a daily basis
again so climate change being one of the
priorities
how does president biden plan to work
with brazil
during the campaign by the criticized
brazil and deforestation
and then the brazilian president
criticized by them back
and he was the last one to congratulate
president biden on his election what is
the expectation for
uh their relationship and does he plan
to speak
with the brazilian president uh well i
don't have anything
uh to predict for you or or advance for
you
in terms of a call or conversation what
i can convey
on climate change of course and
addressing the climate crisis it's one
of the four crises that
he's identified will impact his
administration is impacting not just the
american people but the global community
is that rejoining the paris uh climate
agreement is a vital step
toward doing that the united states was
one of the only countries in the world
as you all know that was
has not been uh has not had a seat at
the table
in the last uh few years uh a little
technical step there
is um we have uh submitted that to the
un secretary general and it will take
approximately 30 days for that to take
place but
i use that as an example because that's
one step but we also know that we need
to be models here at home
as we are addressing an issue like this
the united states continues to be one of
the world's largest emitters
of greenhouse gases and we need to put
in place policies
and take steps here to address that as
well but i'm sure we'll have more to
discuss on brazil in the coming
months um go ahead right there what are
the next steps when it comes to
iran and does the president have any
plans to rejoin the nuclear deal
well the president uh has al has made
clear uh that he believes
that through follow-on diplomacy the
united states should seek to lengthen
and strengthen
nuclear constraints on iran and address
other issues
of concern iran must resume compliance
with significant nuclear constraints
under the deal uh in order for that to
proceed
i will say that as i noted a little bit
earlier um
we would expect that some of his earlier
conversations
with foreign counterparts or foreign
leaders will be with partners and allies
um and that we would certainly
anticipate that this would be part of
the discussion
and then could you just give us some
color about what it was like for him
going into the oval office he's been
waiting for this for so long what was
his reaction
well uh you know i spent a little time
with him earlier and
he uh had an incredible sense of calm
um uh and he uh and in a sense of
some joy uh of course he spent the day
with his family and his
grandchildren and his children and that
always has an impact i think
um but um you know he also said he felt
like he was coming home
remember he spent eight years here as
the vice president uh playing
an important role as a partner uh to
president obama
and um you know that was the emotion
that overtook him today
uh he's also eager to get to work he was
asking questions about
policy and covid and what's next and um
so uh you know that also reflects his
desire to roll up his sleeves and and
get going
uh let's see i'm sorry i told you i was
gonna ask you if i just skipped over
go ahead i'll take it now uh so if
president biden wants
a theme of his presidency to be unifying
the country does he think
that nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
should drop a potentially
divisive senate impeachment trial
well he spoke today as you all saw
about unity in his inaugural address and
the
importance of unity in bringing the
country together
um and the resolve of the american
people in
uh helping to uh get through this moment
um you know we are confident
though that um just like the american
people can
the senate can also multitask
and they can do their constitutional
duty while continuing to
conduct the business of the american
people and his
view is that the way to bring the
country together is to address the
problems we're facing
and so that means getting this covid
relief package through having democrats
and republicans take a serious look at
that and have
conversations with each other about how
to move it forward and he's going to
leave the mechanics the timing and the
specifics
of how congress moves forward on
impeachment to them and
a quick follow-up on president trump's
inauguration day
he filed paperwork to run for reelection
same day
uh does president biden have any plans
to do that
today late or in the coming days
i will say having talked to him today
his his focus is not on politics
it is on uh getting to work and solving
the problems of the american people
uh so and as he noted or uh
on the campaign uh he will wait until uh
sometime
into his first term to speak more about
his uh political plans moving forward
go ahead yeah thank you jen the
president pledged today to repair
alliances
has he planned his first foreign trip
yet well we're only
seven hours in here you're ready for the
foreign trip um
i'm ready too uh i don't have any
details on a foreign trip to
lay out for you at this point in time
hopefully we will at some point in time
go ahead all the way in the back
yeah hi uh congratulations on your new
position uh owen jensen with ewtn global
catholic network
two big concerns for pro-life america
the hyde amendment
which of course uh keeps
tax payer dollars as you know paying for
abortions medicaid abortions
and the mexico city policy which under
the previous administration
expanded to keep tax dollars from
overseas paying for abortions
so what are president what is president
biden planning on doing in those two
items right now
uh well i think we'll have more to say
on the mexico city policy in the coming
days
um uh but i will just take the
opportunity to
remind all of you that he is a devout
catholic and somebody who
attends church regularly uh he started
his day attending church with his family
this morning
um but i don't have anything more for
you on that go ahead
yeah um as president elect he talked
about
the possibilities of using the defense
production act to ramp up the production
of things
um having looked at more data does he
still feel that's necessary was that
included
for example in anything that you signed
today uh well stay tuned
we'll do this again tomorrow and there
may be more specifics to share on plans
on covet tomorrow i expect there will be
including more details on the defense
production act he absolutely
remains committed to invoking the
defense production act
in order to get the supply
and the materials needed to get the
vaccine out
to americans across the country and
remains committed
to his goal of getting 100 million shots
in the arms of americans in the first
hundred days
uh go ahead thank you very much um
the president talked movingly about
unity today
and i've heard from people uh who say
well that's just talk
they want to know what action they're
going to see to show that kind of unity
can you i mean peter mentioned
impeachment
right can you can you tell us what kind
of action we can expect to see
that will assure people that he wants to
reach out to people who voted for him
and people who did not
sure um well first i think anybody who
has covered
president biden for some time or worked
for him or
spent time with him knows that he is
somebody who
always sees the optimistic side of
working with people who may disagree
with him people across the aisle and
that has
long been his uh commitment and desire
through
his many decades in public service um
so his own history tells you how
committed he is
but you know part of it is his words
which he shared today with the american
public on
quite a big stage also his actions he
has reached out to
not just democratic members of congress
but also republicans not just democratic
governors but also republicans not just
democratic mayors but also republicans
and he said today in his speech the
biggest platform
most presidents have through the course
of their presidency that he will govern
for all americans
and uh you know that of course has to be
backed up by actions uh
as you conveyed but uh he's going to uh
venture to um do that in
in every policy he pursues um every
engagement he has
because he feels if we can come together
we'll be a stronger country
go ahead jen will be saying a death
penalty moratorium under this
administration
uh the president uh as you know has
stated his opposition to the death
penalty
uh in the past uh he remains that
remains his view uh
i don't have anything more for you in
terms of future actions or
mechanisms though i can i'll circle back
if there's more i can share with you
on a lighter note will he keep donald
trump's air force one color scheme
change
this is such a good question i have not
had the opportunity to dig into that
today
given the number of executive actions
orders the inauguration
a few things happening um i will venture
to get you an answer on that and maybe
we can talk about it in here tomorrow
i'm judging most people important
letting you follow the computer's
question does
president uh president biden believe
that president trump needs to be held
accountable for the capital insurrection
a couple of weeks ago and does that
accountability
require uh that president trump be
barred from holding
future federal office well um zeke you
know he
uh has spoken very firmly and
fiercely publicly about his views of the
horrific events on the horrific events
on january 6th
and he has also of course spoken with
members of congress about that as you
all know
uh but he is going to leave it to
members of congress to
uh carry out their constitutional duty
and determine what the path forward is
and what the mechanisms are going to be
what the process
will be and what the timeline will be
and
certainly he ran against donald trump
because he did not think he was fit to
serve in office
long before the events of january 6. he
is here today because he decided to run
against him
but we're focusing on moving forward
we're focusing on addressing the
the issues facing the american public uh
and as you know
uh that means we're focused on our
coveted package go ahead if i can follow
up on that a little bit jen is the
president being updated first of all the
progress of the fbi investigation and we
know the fbi is leading the
investigation into the assault
on the capitol does president biden have
confidence in fbi director ray
well peter um as you noted there's an
ongoing investigation which we certainly
support
i'm not sure that he has received an
update today on anything about the
investigation but
uh we certainly support those ongoing um
and we will
i'm sure be receiving updates in the
days ahead of confidence in the fbi
director
i i think i have not spoken with him
about specifically fbi director
ray in recent days uh peter but i'll
circle back with you if there's more to
convey
the president did not mention the word
trump in his inaugural interest today
what was the intention behind not making
any direct reference to his predecessor
in that speech
well i think the intention was to make
the speech not about
any individual elected official any
current
president former president but make it
about the american people
and the moment we're facing in history
right now the
the um struggles that millions of
americans are facing
uh who don't have jobs uh the fear
people have about the health
of their grandparents and their cousins
and their brothers
and to make it more about the strength
of the american people when they come
together
and not about any individual but as as
you saw in his speech it was
forward-looking it was not meant to look
back on the past
go ahead how does president uh plan to
recover the
united states image around the world
and what is his priority globally
well his priority um is first rebuilding
our partnerships and alliances around
the world and regaining
america's seat at the global table and
uh
you can see that is evidenced in his
rejoining the paris climate agreement
rejoining the world health organization
his plans to engage with partners and
allies and
work together to address many of the
threats and issues we're facing around
the world
but i think that is what you will see as
his focus in the weeks ahead
thank you thank you everyone let's do
this again tomorrow
so
so
so